what am i always trying for on this show
solutions so what is the solution
elon musk was there a question
why why make that offer oh so
um
well i think it's very important for
uh there to be
an inclusive arena for
free speech
where
all yeah so uh yeah
twitter has become kind of the de facto
town square
so
it's just really important that people
have the both the uh the reality and the
perception
uh that they're able to speak freely
within the bounds of the law um
and
you know so one of the things that i
believe twitter should do is open source
the algorithm
um and make any changes
uh to people's tweets you know if
they're emphasized or de-emphasized uh
that action should be
made apparent so you can anyone can see
that that action has been taken
so there's no sort of behind-the-scenes
uh manipulation either algorithmically
or
manually um
but
last week guys really get it into your
pores this is the guy that the machine
is now telling you is evil this is the
guy that the corporate press is now
telling you is the bad guy the guy who
is saying oh there should be more
transparency there should be more
honesty there should be more voices
there should be a more even playing
field and this is exactly the same
as to what they did to joe rogan a month
and a half ago because he was willing to
have conversations with
basically the world's foremost expert on
the mrna technology so i'm trying to
show you how the machine
operates around people that are trying
to just
have an honest conversation
just have a a place to talk where
there's a little messiness on the
fringes where we can think for ourselves
and figuring things out but there is an
entire superstructure that exists the
corporate press to make sure that you
cannot see that
and oh do we have an example and this is
where i do we have the warning can we
throw the warning up is it a little late
for we've got the warning the content
advisory what you're about to see is
pure [ __ ] we have to put that up
before we put on these people over at
msnbc this is the mental institution
pretending to be a news network this is
joy reid she is a racist
psychotic american-hating lunatic but
she found a guest that's even worse than
her here you go so look at musk musk
has built his business through
government subsidies years ago and now
turns around stiffs the government on
taxes and and explains how inefficient
government spending is and he can do
everything better privately in space and
elsewhere
he is
building in tesla a documentedly racist
company that perhaps reminds him
gives him nostalgic memories of
apartheid south africa where he grew up
that that is a disgusting human being
right there like it is pretty hard i
don't know how the booker the booker
should get a freaking award because to
find a guest who is worse than joy reid
is is a rather extraordinary thing to do
like somebody should get an award can we
send them a cake let's sell them donuts
let's send them a box of donuts you
found a guest worse than your horrible
host first off the implica okay tesla is
a documentedly racist company that is
the most insane thing yes he's
it's not even worth talking about you
get it this guy is just an idiot then he
tries to link it back to south africa
somehow implying that that elon musk and
his family were somehow for apartheid
like it's just it's just the most awful
worse stuff and also related to all the
tax stuff and everything else uh if elon
musk has broke the law and stiff the
government on taxes the government would
be coming after him now the government
comes after plenty of good people who
aren't worthy of coming after but the
point is if he uses the tax subsidies
that the government allows that doesn't
mean the tax subsidies are good right uh
hate the game not the player right this
was what they were always trying to get
trump on trump did all these things that
are perfectly legal i'm angry at trump
and it's like all right if you don't
like the tax code then change the tax
code